this video is brought to you by
surfshark today's topic so somebody sent
me some link to some tick tocks that had
us in it and I thought it was
interesting because this very Tick Tock
is the one that got us banned but
apparently it's made the rounds on Tick
Tock a little bit and I want to see it
well that's just stupid then
let's watch it
would you date a trans person no no
sorry but that's pretty discriminatory
it's not it's officially not and it's
not even transphobic if you're not into
somebody because they're transgender
nobody on this planet has to explain why
they're interested in a certain
demographic and that includes race
gender body type anything you don't have
to explain why you're attracted to that
some people like big titties some people
like small titties some people like dick
some people don't some people like
feminine dick some people don't
we're done based we're done facts we're
done
truth okay the verdict
you guilty
of Spain facts congratulations I haven't
the [ __ ] you want me to say you did it
Bing's dot said everything not gonna lie
that's not what I was expecting don't
know what feminine dick is I'm not gonna
lie
Don't Wanna Know
not gonna lie
that speech was fire
congratulations congratulations it's all
about how you swing and what you care
about I just think it's kind of funny
that you're trying to perpetuate the
[ __ ] that is discriminatory or
transphobic for you to not be attracted
to a trans individual is because
literally no other demographic
ever does that when it comes to sex
someone with big tits doesn't say you're
discriminating on me because I have big
tits people that are gay don't even say
that nobody says that wire
I don't get it
besides if somebody is clearly
exclaiming that they're not interested
in you because you're transgender then
go find somebody else because they
clearly don't like all of who you are
and you should put the standard up a
little bit and find somebody that likes
you for everything
shut it off we're done
shut it off
what topic you want to appreciate
[ __ ] just smirked it what the
[ __ ] do you want I just want to
appreciate this been on for a couple
months
and this is a video that we got banned
for
what's [ __ ] yeah what's [ __ ] up is
other people are making money and are
being able to to to to comment on that
while we that's the [ __ ] up part the
rest you said what you said I mean shout
outs shut up shut up shout outs today
shout out to that person but it just
[ __ ] up that one video game and other
people ah okay cool so big comment all
right it depends who comments on it is
that what it is anyways carry on hey
sometimes you want to watch certain
videos from other countries and you can
because your country is not allowed I
know well you need to get yourself a VPN
changer a VPN changer is something
that's gonna change the location of your
computer I'm from Canada and our Netflix
is nice but it's not like the US Netflix
or the UK Netflix or anything else no or
any Netflix around the world and
sometimes I want to be able to enjoy
that content well I just teleport my
computer with the VPN changer wherever I
want it to be and I can enjoy whatever
content I want and now now if you if you
you go on the link below you use the
code Abba and breach you're gonna to be
able to save 85 percent and have three
first month for free I know I know go
right now click on the link below and
you know let your computer travel
and you will enjoy all the content that
you want
to try that's not it's not
discriminatory it's not transphobic and
it's not Prejudice it's a preference I
prefer people with ginger hair my
girlfriend's Ginger but you won't call
me ginger fire because I didn't want to
date her because she's Ginger literally
a false narrative like just stop I am
trans we all know this if someone told
me that they don't want to date because
I'm trans that's completely fine to me
don't get me wrong because I do
understand why some people do get upset
about it but it is not transphobic like
stop trying to make people feel bad
because they just don't want to date you
I've said this before and I'll say it
again I personally wouldn't date a trans
person either wrap it up wrap this [ __ ]
up the only thing I'm pissed about is
people being able to make because people
are trans they're able to make comments
on that video but we can't is that the
only thing that that's the only thing
that that's crazy because it's like
we're being told you and I are being
told we are somehow discriminated yeah
because we're like we're not just open
to it we're not open to it but they say
the same speech without video and it's
fine that's what gets me not even their
speech shout outs to them shout out to
uh the first person the second person
shout out to them what really gets me is
really that so you shot off the whole
account
because we said that and we sis but you
oh wow that's so crazy wow that's so
crazy but that's just the way it works
on these platforms are we still are we
still a lot of Count's been dead we
haven't been able to repost on it so it
is what it is it's interesting how that
works and you see that the moderation on
these platforms are full of [ __ ]
that's what it is because this video is
still up there and a bunch of people
posted and these are big numbers that
they're getting but we posted the same
thing the original one and then we got
paid for it and we get numbers it's
funny how gender changes sits away gang
gang
it is the best is that what it is that
and that's why I've heard a lot of trans
people say that like they wouldn't it's
fine
some people are open to it some people
are into it okay
keep it pushing why would anybody watch
how to change people's minds just who
cares move on but would you feel the
same if someone said they didn't want to
date up like yeah I would I don't know
go do whatever you want to do that
person doesn't want to date me because
I'm black that person's right yeah you
should date me now I'm gonna want to
date a person what the [ __ ] is wrong
with you what the [ __ ] is wrong I don't
even think it makes the [ __ ] is wrong
with you it doesn't make them
you want to date someone that doesn't
want to date you yes the [ __ ] there you
go what the [ __ ] is wrong with you well
we need to get away from like oh you're
somehow kind of like some problematic
person no not everyone has to be open to
everything keep it pushing
it's crazy in this team but like body
autonomy and your choice is your choice
and you can [ __ ] abort babies and do
all this other stuff okay great
give up your baby for you do whatever
the [ __ ] you want is your body to do
anything
you say I don't want to give it up to
these kind of people oh we got a problem
now what what are we even talking about
right now
but you can't say this online in public
because the way the narrative works is
that's a problem for some reason and
it's such a stupid point you know like
there are a couple of cultural talking
points that are so [ __ ] stupid and
just need to be let go that if folks let
them go acceptance would come much
easier because some of it is ridiculous
you want to be called whatever pronoun
absolutely fine you want to use it I
don't care you want to get medical
treatment as a site fly with me I don't
care I support it I hope you get it
but the whole Sports thing is like if
you don't want to date you try bruh you
losing people you are now trying to
govern people's minds to tell them what
they should and shouldn't want to [ __ ]
and you think you good at Garner support
that's the kind of stuff that turns
people off completely it's not
and the fact that people can't say this
[ __ ] openly without being banned or
without like some news agency saying we
don't support this kind of what are you
talking about
what are we even talk about
and this is the kind of stuff that makes
people look at the Western world like
goofy ass [ __ ] it is weird
yeah I think it's dope that these people
said it and that they said it so bluntly
and it's great to see folks from that
community be able to talk about this
stuff because like if I say anything
it's like well you don't realize the
kind of internalized trance what the
[ __ ] are you talking about everyone's
transphobic you just don't realize it
even these trans people oh my God okay
but I'm glad you guys can talk about it
so yeah oh [ __ ]
um
yeah I'm not mad about that no more
if you could use your trans privilege if
you talk about the message well the
message goes on then I'm fine they
usually they privilege they the message
is out there
[ __ ] they usually mean trans privilege
yeah we should be able to say this [ __ ]
publicly it's not a big deal it's not
like I go out of my way to say this [ __ ]
I don't care so I see people say stuff
like oh you're a a foe or something
because you're not dumb so I'm like no I
gotta say but me saying it make it sound
like I really care that dude like I've
never talked about this in real life or
had these conversations anywhere else
it's not even like a video topic but I
see this like viral video going around
with her spreading this kind of [ __ ]
and people in the comments be like yeah
this is a problem I see Reddit posts of
people being guilt-tripped and called
like all kinds of crazy names because
they say they're not open I'm like what
the [ __ ] is this this is like a common
thing in some circles no this is [ __ ]
talk
you can't say that word remedial [ __ ]
I don't care bro whatever it's like it's
just dumb but you have to date them
stuff I just think it was crazy I was
watching these videos and I was like I
can't believe these are still up and
we've been bam for months for this one
video it's so crazy but maybe you guys
feel differently you know that's Tick
Tock it is what it is whatever I know
it's getting off my back let us know
what you guys oh my God